From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira glass. Today our program comes to you from a club on Chicago's North Side, The Lunar Cabaret. And we're here to conduct a little radio experiment.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目是在芝加哥北区的一家俱乐部——月球歌舞厅为您录制的。我们在这里进行一个小小的广播实验。
Over the last two weeks here in Chicago, we have advertised, we have asked for people to come in here today with letters, letters they've found, letters they've been sent, letters they have sent. And what we're going to do is conduct an open mic session. Basically, let people come up and read their letters.
在过去的两周里，我们在芝加哥发布了征集启事，邀请大家带着信件来到现场——无论是他们发现的、别人寄给他们的，还是他们自己写出的信件。我们要做的就是举办一场开放麦活动，让人们上台朗读他们的信件。
And we've asked people to change the names in the letters to protect both the innocent and the guilty. Otherwise, the ground rule is, these letters are real. I'll be co-hosting today's show with playwright David Hauptschein. And it's David who actually created the idea of the letter show. He's done this several times around Chicago, invited people to bring in their letters and read them on stage. He's also done a diary show, where people have read from their diaries, and a true stories show, where people come up on stage, and just tell true stories.
我们要求人们更改信中的名字，以保护当事人。除此之外，基本原则是：这些信件都是真实的。我将与剧作家大卫·霍普沙因共同主持今天的节目。正是大卫创造了“信件秀”这个点子。他在芝加哥举办过好几次这样的活动，邀请人们带来他们的信件并在舞台上朗读。他还做过日记秀，让人们朗读自己的日记，还有真实故事秀，让人们上台讲述真实的故事。
David, thank you for agreeing to try this on the radio.
大卫，谢谢你同意在广播里尝试这个想法。
Well, thank you, Ira, for having me.
嗯，谢谢你，艾拉，邀请我参加。
All right. So how do we begin this? What are the rules? What do people need to know?
好的。那么我们该如何开始呢？规则是什么？人们需要了解什么？
There are a few basic rules. You see this egg timer here? My grandmother made soft-boiled eggs for me when I was eight years old using this egg timer. This egg timer will get you off the stage after five minutes. When you hear [DING] that, you must stop. If you're really nervous, I usually bring a pillow for people to rest their heads on, but tonight I have this little elephant for people to hold in case they're really--
有几个基本规则。你看到这个计时器了吗？我八岁时，我祖母就是用这个计时器给我煮溏心蛋的。这个计时器会在五分钟后让你下台。当你听到“叮”的一声，你就必须停下来。如果你真的很紧张，我通常会带一个枕头给人们垫着头，但今晚我准备了这个小象，以防有人真的——
He's holding up a--
他举起了一个——
It's a rhino. Sorry, sorry, sorry.
是犀牛。抱歉，抱歉，抱歉。
You're holding up a six inch long, gray rhinoceros.
你举起的是一个六英寸长的灰色犀牛模型。
And I will leave this up here on the podium. So if anyone gets really tense-- which is fine, you're allowed to be nervous-- just hang on to this.
我会把它留在讲台上。所以如果有人感到非常紧张——这没关系，你可以紧张——就抓着它好了。
I hold in my hand a bowl, a silver bowl, full of pieces of paper on which members of our audience here have written their names.
我手里拿着一个银碗，里面装满了我们观众写的名字。
Please pick the first name, Ira.
请抽第一个名字，艾拉。
John Biederman. come on up.
约翰·比德曼。请上来。
It's always a very strange and powerful thing to be first.
第一个出场总是一件非常奇怪且有力量的事情。
OK, I'll read you a couple of things from Carolyn. Down the side of this, has listed a few band names, White Snake, Judas Priest, Ozzy, Led Zepplin, Motley Crue, Accept, Iron Maiden, Black Rose, Giuffria. Whatever the hell--
好的，我来读几件卡罗琳的东西。在这张纸的边缘，她列举了一些乐队的名字：白蛇乐队、犹大圣徒、奥兹、齐柏林飞艇、克鲁小丑、Accept、铁娘子、黑玫瑰、Giuffria。管他什么——
Hiya hon', what are you up to? I'm listening to Motley Crue, "Shout at the Devil." That's a pretty kick-ass tape. It's Joe's, but it's still a kick-ass tape. And Vince Neil is such a fox. I'd love to go backstage at a Crue concert. I'd be in total heaven, because I know what I'd do. And I'll bet you do too.
嗨，亲爱的，你在干嘛？我在听克鲁小丑的《向恶魔呐喊》。那磁带真的很棒。是乔的，但磁带真的很带劲。文斯·尼尔真是个迷人的家伙。我真想去克鲁小丑演唱会的后台。我会进入纯粹的天堂，因为我知道我会做什么。我敢打赌你也知道。
Like my green marker? I think it's cool. Explain this to me. Something fishy is going on. What? I don't know. But you're acting fishy. So don't lie. And it's nothing I did. I don't act any different than before we did it. Are you trying to say that I'm acting different, or I'm slightly more insane than usual? Is that what you mean, I'm acting differently? If that's what you mean, how?
喜欢我的绿色记号笔吗？我觉得很酷。给我解释一下这个。有什么猫腻正在发生。什么？我不知道。但你的行为很可疑。所以别撒谎。这和我没关系。我表现得和我们发生关系前没两样。你是想说我的行为不同了，还是我比平时更疯狂了一点？你是这个意思吗，我表现得不一样了？如果你是这个意思，那怎么表现的？
I just heard Judas Priest, Dokken, and Dio. That's pretty kick-ass.
我刚刚听了犹大圣徒、Dokken和Dio。真的很棒。
Why did Chris ask for me today? And why did you guys hang up on me? That's pretty ignorant, not to mention, immature and rude.
克里斯今天为什么要找我？你们为什么要挂我电话？这真是无知，更别提不成熟和粗鲁了。
I'm listening to Motley Crue, "Bastard" again. So they are so cool. I haven't decided if I like Crue or Maiden better yet, but they're both totally kick-ass.
我正在听克鲁小丑的《混蛋》又一遍。他们真是太酷了。我还没决定我更喜欢克鲁还是铁娘子，但她们都棒极了。
Know what mine and Tracy's new word is? [BLEEP]. That's right. For the last two days, we've been calling every one [BLEEP]. Nice name, eh? Not as good as [BLEEP] or [BLEEP], but it's right up there.
知道我和特雷西的新词是什么吗？[消音]。没错。过去两天，我们管每个人都叫[消音]。好名字，对吧？虽然不如[消音]或[消音]好，但也差不多了。
God is this note [BLEEP] dumb. It's 7:38. And I want it to be 8:38, because then I can listen to RPM, Real Precious Metal, 103.1, 831-1031-- kick-ass. "Helter Skelter," you ain't maybe a lover, but you ain't no dancer, helter skelter.
天哪，这张便条真是[消音]蠢。现在是7:38。我希望是8:38，因为那样我就能听RPM，《珍贵金属》，103.1频率，831-1031——太棒了。“混乱”，你也许不是个情人，但你绝不是个舞者，混乱。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
What happened to the NPR crowd? That's more of a college rock station there. Yeah. OK, Ira.
NPR的听众怎么了？那是大学摇滚电台的风格。好吧，艾拉。
Next reader Neal Pollack.
下一位朗读者，尼尔·波拉克。
Coming from all the way in the back, approaching the stage.
从最后面走上来，正在靠近舞台。
Hi. I wrote-- can I hold this?
嗨。我写了——我可以拿着这个吗？
Please do.
请便。
Neil is holding the rhinoceros.
尼尔手里拿着那只犀牛。
I wrote these letters soon after I graduated from college. And I like to turn back to them, every now and then, to remind myself what an idiot I was. I believed at the time that I could get any job I wanted, anywhere, at any point. And these letters, I think, are indicative. Here's one I wrote to Tina Brown, who was then the editor of Vanity Fair magazine.
我在大学毕业后不久写了这些信。我偶尔喜欢回过头来看一看，提醒自己当时有多傻。那时我坚信自己可以在任何时候、任何地点得到任何想要的工作。我想这些信就是证明。这是我写给蒂娜·布朗的一封，她当时是《名利场》杂志的编辑。
Dear Ms. Brown, I'll cut to the quick. I would like to work for The New Yorker . And I imagine with the big change-over, you may need lots of editorial help. So I'm throwing my hat into the ring, and asking you to consider hiring me as an editorial assistant for your new project.
亲爱的布朗女士，长话短说。我想为《纽约客》工作。我想随着重大人事变动，你们可能需要很多编辑方面的帮手。所以我毛遂自荐，希望您考虑聘用我作为新项目的编辑助理。
I've been precociously reading The New Yorker for some time now. And I am a devotee of the current magazine, as well as of its historical heritage. Most of the writers I respect most, living and dead, have written for your magazine at some time. I'm willing to cut my journalistic and literary teeth elsewhere, if can't get a job at The New Yorker , but I'm determined not to end up anywhere else.
我一直都在超前阅读《纽约客》。我是这本杂志现在的忠实读者，也热爱它的历史传承。我最尊敬的绝大多数作家，无论健在与否，都曾为你们杂志写过文章。如果无法在《纽约客》工作，我愿意在别处磨练我的新闻和文学功底，但我下定决心不去其他任何地方。
The resume I've enclosed doesn't indicate this, but I've been working as a freelance writer since graduating two months ago. I've been doing pretty well, but I'm still waiting for the big score. Maybe you could help. I strongly encourage you to take a chance on me, but if I don't suit your needs at this time, thank you for reviewing my application. I look forward to hearing from you.
虽然简历上没写，但我从两个月前毕业起就一直在做自由撰稿人。我干得还不错，但还在等待那个大机会。也许您可以帮我。我强烈建议您给我一个机会，但如果此时不符合您的需求，谢谢您审阅我的申请。期待您的回复。
About six months later, I hadn't yet heard from Tina Brown so I turned my gaze elsewhere. Here's one I wrote to Strobe Talbott, who, at the time, was an editor-at-large at Time magazine, and now, as you may or may not know, is a Deputy Secretary of State in the Clinton administration. So here's what I wrote to Strobe.
大约六个月后，我还没收到蒂娜·布朗的消息，所以我把目光转向了别处。这是我写给斯特罗布·塔尔博特的，他当时是《时代》杂志的特约编辑，现在，或许你听说过，他是克林顿政府的副国务卿。这就是我写给斯特罗布的内容。
Dear Mr. Talbott, I'm a damn good editor. I'm young and gutsy, as a marine in combat. My terse, tough prose style would make Raymond Chandler weep. Somewhere, somehow, the grapevine told me that you're starting a magazine called, Globe Review . Said vine also let me know that the staff will be small, which means you're not hiring too many people. Being low man on the totem pole is fine with me.
亲爱的塔尔博特先生，我是一名该死的好编辑。我年轻而有胆识，就像战场上的海军陆战队员。我简练、强硬的文风会让雷蒙德·钱德勒落泪。不知何故，小道消息告诉我，你正在创办一本叫《环球评论》的杂志。消息还说员工人数会很少，这意味着你不会招太多人。在食物链底端工作对我来说没问题。
Your magazine sounds original, smart, and progressive, sophisticated but not shallow. Of course, I'm just guessing. Can you go global without me? I think so. Should you? I think not. Or at least hope not. I'll do good work as an assistant editor, copy editor, or researcher. I'll be in New York City from November 11 through 17. If you'd like to interview me, you can contact me at the Chicago address on my resume until then. Thank you for reviewing my application. And I look forward to seeing the magazine, whether I am part of it or not.
你的杂志听起来原创、聪明、进步，成熟但不肤浅。当然，这只是我的猜测。没有我，你能走向全球吗？我想可以。但你应该这样做吗？我认为不应该。或者至少希望不要。作为助理编辑、校对或研究员，我会做好工作。我将于11月11日至17日在纽约市。如果你想面试我，在那之前你可以通过简历上的芝加哥地址联系我。谢谢你审阅我的申请。无论我是否会参与其中，我都期待看到这本杂志。
Thank you. Ready for another one?
谢谢。准备好听下一封了吗？
Joseph Silovsky.
约瑟夫·西洛夫斯基。
I collect letters. These first three are ones that I found in a dumpster on Roosevelt Street. First one's July 6, 1982. Dear friends and well wishers, due to the circumstances beyond our control, the wedding which was scheduled for July 24, 1982 has been canceled. Sorry if this has inconvenienced you in the way. Respectfully, D and R.
我收集信件。前三封是我在罗斯福街的一个垃圾箱里发现的。第一封是1982年7月6日。亲爱的朋友和祝福者们，由于不可抗力，原定于1982年7月24日举行的婚礼已被取消。若造成不便，深表歉意。敬上，D和R。
The second is from the City of Chicago Department of Police. Dear Mr. R., since the registration of your complaint, investigation has been made concerning possible misconduct by a member of our department. A complete record of the complaint and investigation is now part of our file and will be used in planning, training, and updating equipment in our continuing effort to better provide service and protection to the public. We share your concern relative to the conduct of our members and appreciate your bringing this matter to our attention.
第二封来自芝加哥警察局。亲爱的R先生，自从收到您的投诉后，我们已针对本部门一名成员可能存在的不当行为进行了调查。投诉和调查的完整记录现已成为我们档案的一部分，并将用于规划、培训和更新设备，以持续改进我们对公众的服务和保护。我们与您一样关注我们成员的行为，并感谢您将此事告知我们。
Although evidence in this case failed to justify the taking of disciplinary action against the accused member, the department as a whole has benefited by having taken a closer look at the performance of our member. Thank you for your cooperation in this matter.
尽管本案证据不足以证明对被指控成员采取纪律处分，但通过重新审视该成员的表现，整个部门都受益匪浅。感谢您在此事中的配合。
The third is a letter that has his apartment number written on the back, so it was obviously just dropped off at the building. Oh, it's 9/15/1984. Hey R., thank you very much for being there when I needed you last night. Rejection must be your number one priority. You have done it once more again.
第三封信的背面写着他的公寓号码，很明显是直接塞进大楼的。哦，日期是1984年9月15日。嘿R，非常感谢你昨晚在我需要的时候出现。拒绝肯定是你首要的任务。你又做了一次。
You told me to give my mother her keys back and come to your place a few weeks ago. And I told you, when I was ready to move in, I would. And I would let you know. I wasn't asking to move in. I was asking for a place to stay for the night. I spent last weekend down there. But this weekend and I'm not qualified. If you don't want me in your apartment anymore, then you should say so. I understand our situation, but I do have props. I am the first lady you've dealt with to become Mrs. R., therefore, I am special in your life. You may not want to admit it, but it's true.
几周前你告诉我把钥匙还给我妈妈，然后去你那儿。我告诉过你，当我准备好搬进去的时候，我会搬的。我会让你知道的。我并不是要求搬进去。我只是要求有一个晚上可以住的地方。上个周末我住在那里。但这个周末，我没有资格了。如果你不想让我再住你的公寓，那就直说。我理解我们的处境，但我确实有道具。我是你交往过的第一位成为R太太的女士，因此，我在你的生命中是特殊的。你可能不想承认，但这是事实。
It's obvious that you are seeing somebody else, in which you are entitled. But I should have top priority. Nevertheless, I hope you and your lady that's expecting your child to be very happy. Don't worry about me and my pregnancy. I'll be just fine. I don't want to come in between anyone's happy affair. You must have let our secret out about the divorce to her, in order for you to be so comfortable to have sex with her. I thought we agreed years ago that we would remain sex partners, if nothing else. However it be, I hope your wish comes true.
很明显你在和别人约会，这是你的权利。但我应该有优先权。尽管如此，我希望你和你那个怀了你孩子的女士能非常幸福。别担心我和我的怀孕。我会很好。我不想插足任何人的快乐恋情。你一定是为了能和她舒服地发生关系，才把我们离婚的秘密告诉了她。我以为我们几年前就达成协议了，如果我们不能成为别的，至少可以保持性伴侣关系。无论如何，希望你能如愿以偿。
You are totally responsible for my unhappiness, depression, and confused state of mind that I am in. You are always doing the same thing over, and over, and over. Will you ever change? For someone to have been in love-- and still is, per you-- you sure treat the party you're supposed to be in love with cruel. As often as I've been through the same ordeal with you, I don't know why I continue to allow myself to be hurt by you. I am often hurt by the things you say to me, and your actions or ways towards me.
你完全要为我目前的不幸、抑郁和困惑的状态负责。你总是在重复同样的事情，一次又一次。你会有所改变吗？作为一个曾经相爱——据你说现在依然——的人，你对待那个理应相爱的人真是残酷。虽然我经历过同样的事情无数次，我不知道为什么我继续让自己被你伤害。我经常被你说的话，以及你对待我的方式或行为所伤。
You are my life, friend, enemy, joy, sorrow, husband, lover, and that has been taken away from me. I have not got over the shocking news of us being divorced. Being with someone for nine years is not easy to brush under the rug. You try telling yourself that it's over, and it doesn't work. I am trying to be friends with you if nothing else.
你是我的生命，朋友，敌人，快乐，悲伤，丈夫，情人，而这一切都被从我身边夺走了。我还没从我们离婚的震惊消息中走出来。和一个人在一起九年，不是那么容易被掩盖过去的。你试着告诉自己一切都结束了，但这没用。如果不能成为别的，我正在试着和你做朋友。
And it goes on and on about that for a while. And then the end is--
后面还有很长一段内容。最后结尾是——
I love you now and always will. You will be number one in my life, whether we're together or not. If ever you need me, just send for me, and I'm just a phone call away. Love, D. PS, inform me if you have a boy, a girl, or twins, and I will do the same.
我现在爱你，永远爱你。无论我们是否在一起，你都将是我生命中的第一位。如果你需要我，随时叫我，我一个电话就会到。爱你的，D。附言：如果你生的是男孩、女孩还是双胞胎，请告诉我，我也会这样做。
You're listening to a special edition of This American Life . We're coming to you from a theater in Chicago, a very small, intimate theater where people have come with real letters they've received, letters they've sent, letters they've found to read on stage. Our next reader, pulled from our bowl of readers. Katherine Corcoran, come on up.
你正在收听的是《美国生活》的特别版。我们在芝加哥的一家剧院录制节目，这是一家非常小、非常亲密的剧院，人们带着收到的真实信件、发出的信件、发现的信件，来到这里上台朗读。下一位朗读者，从我们的读者碗里抽出来的。凯瑟琳·科科兰，请上来。
If you have, and return winning prize claim number, we'll say, Lucy Corcoran, you've cleared the final hurdle. You're Illinois' top winner, guaranteed a full $11 million. Your earlier entry has been received and is being processed. And now, you've been issued a specially coded, prize category tag. Break open your security pouch, Lucy Corcoran.
如果您有并寄回获奖领奖编号，我们要说，露西·科科兰，你已经清除了最后一道障碍。你是伊利诺伊州的最高获胜者，保证获得整整1100万美元。你之前的参赛作品已收到并正在处理中。现在，你获得了一个特制编码的奖项类别标签。撕开你的安全袋，露西·科科兰。
Say for our radio listeners.
为我们的广播听众读一下。
Oh, I broke open the security pouch.
哦，我撕开了安全袋。
You're breaking open the pouch right now. Silvery pouch.
你现在正在撕开袋子。银色的袋子。
Yes. It was affixed to the letter. I saved it just for this moment. This extra entry is guaranteed to make you one of Illinois' top prize winners of all time, with up to $11 million, if you have and return the winning prize claim number before August 9. If your tag is specially coded with the letter A--
是的。它贴在信上。我为了这一刻保留着它。这个额外的参赛机会保证让你成为伊利诺伊州有史以来最高的奖项获得者之一，最高可达1100万美元，如果你在8月9日之前拥有并寄回获奖领奖编号的话。如果你的标签上特别编码了字母A——
It is. You're holding it up.
是的。你举起来了。
--it's coded with the letter A, you'll really want to hurry, Lucy Corcoran, because you stand to win $1 million, $75,000, or an unbelievable $11 million fortune.
——它编码着字母A，你真的需要抓紧时间了，露西·科科兰，因为你有望赢取100万美元、7.5万美元，或者令人难以置信的1100万美元财富。
Here's another reason to act quickly. Over 8,000 winners from across the Prairie State have already claimed and been awarded their prizes, including Sparky Weiner of Chicago, Sparky Lawrence of Justice, Sparky Bailey of Chicago, and, category A winner, Sparky Peterson of Chicago.
这是另一个尽快行动的理由。来自大草原之州的8000多名获胜者已经领取并获得了他们的奖品，包括芝加哥的斯帕基·韦纳、正义市的斯帕基·劳伦斯、芝加哥的斯帕基·贝利，以及A类获胜者，芝加哥的斯帕基·彼得森。
But time is running out, Lucy Corcoran. The exact prize you qualify for is hidden beneath the silver box on your prize category tag. So if you haven't yet scratched it off, we urge you to grab a lucky coin. I don't have one. I'm scratching it off. Oh no. I'm going to wish I had one. And do it now. And do so, now.
但时间不多了，露西·科科兰。你符合的具体奖项隐藏在奖项类别标签上的银色方框下。所以如果你还没有刮开它，我们建议你拿一枚幸运硬币。我没有硬币。我正在刮开它。哦，不。我希望我有一枚。现在就做。现在就做。
If you uncover the code word, 11 mil-- and I did-- and your prize claim number is also the winner, we'll say, Lucy Corcoran is officially declared the biggest winner in Illinois history, and will be paid our first ever $11 million prize. You're second to none, Lucy Corcoran, in a league of your own with gigantic $366,666 prize checks pouring in, every year for 30 years, if you win. In the blink of an eye, you'd be magically transformed into a fabulously rich multimillionaire, free from money worries ever more. Would you stay in Chicago, or custom build your dream home in another part of Illinois? Would you embark on a cruise around the world, or crisscross the country in a fully loaded motor home?
如果你揭开了代码词“1100万”——我揭开了——并且你的领奖编号也是获胜者，我们说，露西·科科兰正式被宣布为伊利诺伊州历史上最大的获胜者，并将被支付我们有史以来第一个1100万美元的奖项。你是首屈一指的，露西·科科兰，如果你赢了，将会有巨额的366,666美元的奖金支票，每年汇出，持续30年。在眨眼之间，你就会神奇地变身为一个极其富有的千万富翁，从此再也不用担心钱的问题。你会留在芝加哥，还是在伊利诺伊州的其他地方量身定做你的梦想家园？你会开启一次环球航行，还是开着装满设备的房车横穿全国？
It may sound like a dream to you now, but it will be your dream to bring to life if you have and return the winning prize number. So hold on to your dream, Lucy Corcoran, but don't hold on to this entry. Remember, you must reply before August 9 to advance to the winner selection step. Please, don't let anything stand in your way. Hurry. And then it's cordially signed by-- oh, there's more, but-- cordially signed by, Ed McMahon, or Ed "Sparky" Jones, and Sparky Clark for American Family Publishers. Thank you.
这对你来说现在可能听起来像是个梦，但如果你拥有并寄回了获奖领奖编号，它将成为你梦想成真的时刻。所以坚持你的梦想，露西·科科兰，但不要守着这张入场券不放。记住，你必须在8月9日之前回复，以推进到获胜者选择步骤。请不要让任何事情挡住你的路。快点。最后它由——哦，还有更多，但——由埃德·麦克马洪，或埃德“斯帕基”琼斯，以及美国家庭出版公司的斯帕基·克拉克诚挚签署。谢谢。
I'd go with the motor home, myself. Definitely, that's my dream.
我会选那辆房车。绝对的，那就是我的梦想。
Our next reader, Adam Davidson.
下一位读者，亚当·戴维森。
This is age 16. Dear Adam, I can lose my guard best when I write. No wonder I scared off S with my letters. Speaking of which, I didn't hear from him. You see, how can I ever think of hurting you like that? Let's say something starts between us. What about S? I may not like him, but maybe I do. Also, what if I'm just on the rebound from Dave? Not that I didn't like you before. Maybe I'm just free to say it now. But I might be exaggerating it, because I'm feeling a loss. Maybe we're confusing a really good friendship for love, et cetera. You know the deal.
这是16岁时写的。亲爱的亚当，我写东西的时候最能卸下心防。难怪我用我的信吓跑了S。说到这个，我没收到他的信。你看，我怎么会想到那样伤害你呢？假设我们之间开始点什么。那S呢？我不一定喜欢他，但也许喜欢。另外，如果我只是和戴夫分手后的反弹期呢？并不是我以前不喜欢你。也许我只是现在可以自由地说出来了。但我可能夸大了，因为我感到一种失落。也许我们把非常好的友谊误认为是爱情等等。你懂的。
Also, let's say we do have sex. It'll be a bigger deal for you. Not that I won't take it seriously. I have seriously thought about it. But it's a big responsibility to put on me, your first time, et cetera.
另外，假设我们真的发生了关系。这对你来说会是一件大事。并不是说我不认真对待。我认真想过。但那是很大的责任，你的第一次等等。
Now who's babbling? Anyway, I think you're a wonderful person and friend, and the last thing I want to do is screw that up. Maybe we should just see, trial run, if making out agrees with us. You never know, we might decide it doesn't feel right and keep things status quo. Or we might end up getting it on every day.
现在是谁在胡言乱语？总之，我觉得你是一个很棒的人和朋友，我最不想做的事就是搞砸这点。也许我们应该试一试，实验一下，看看接吻是否适合我们。你永远不知道，我们可能会决定这感觉不对，然后保持现状。或者我们最终可能会每天都那样。
Excuse the vulgar language. As that guy in English class would say, there is no pretty way to look at sex. Anyway, I love you, but I'm not sure what kind of love. Love, K.
请原谅粗俗的语言。正如英语课上那个家伙所说，看待性没有美化的方式。总之，我爱你，但我不知道是哪种爱。爱你的，K。
Geez, I don't even know what attracts me to you. You're so [BLEEP] perfect, I guess.
天哪，我甚至不知道什么吸引我靠近你。你太[消音]完美了，我想。
And then, supplementary letter.
然后是补充信件。
Will things be the same once the sexual tension is gone? I think that's half the fun. It's what has kept Moonlighting on the air. Will we still be able to joke about getting married, et cetera, without feeling uncomfortable? Confusion. Is there an S in confusion? I'm even mixed up about that.
一旦性紧张消失，一切还会一样吗？我想那占了一半的乐趣。那是《蓝色月光》能够持续播出的原因。我们还能开结婚之类的玩笑吗，而不感到不舒服？困惑。Confusion里有个S吗？我连这个都搞不清了。
We went out after that for a year.
在那之后我们又约会了一年。
Jeff Dorchen.
杰夫·多钦。
I read this letter a little while ago, and I might have trouble reading it, because the handwriting is weird. It's from a friend of mine. He wrote to me, this was like seven or eight years ago. Well, no. When was the Gulf War? Five years ago. It was during the Gulf War, the first Gulf War, Bush's Gulf War. It was a guy I met in Morocco. And he was in the '68 student revolt in France, in Paris, actually, in Saint-Etienne. And the stationary is from the Hotel Adriatico, where he actually wasn't staying when he wrote the letter. He stole the paper.
我不久前读过这封信，我读起来可能会有点困难，因为字迹很奇怪。是一个朋友给我的。他在大概七八年前写给我的。嗯，不对。海湾战争是什么时候？五年前。是在海湾战争期间，第一次海湾战争，布什的海湾战争。是一个我在摩洛哥认识的人。他参加了法国的学生运动，其实是在圣艾蒂安。信纸是亚得里亚酒店的，他写信的时候其实并不住在那里。他偷了信纸。
Dear Jeff, it's a joke. Today I went to the concert against the war. Many people-- thanks to Bush, Hussein, Mitterrand, and so-- all the old chaps went out from their quiet routines, and we met again, speaking and debating like in the '70s. Hee hee.
亲爱的杰夫，这真是一个笑话。今天我去参加了反战音乐会。很多人——多亏了布什、侯赛因、密特朗等等——所有的老家伙都走出了他们安静的日常，我们又见面了，像70年代那样交谈和辩论。嘿嘿。
Many young people here, many people here know, as a fact, that the voice of the TV is a weapon against their liberty of thinking. Since the war is the central point of the universal propaganda, the great lie of democracy is becoming obvious. Liberty is slavery. Democracy is dictative. Left is right. Everything is true as well as its contrary.
这里有很多年轻人，很多人都知道，电视的声音是反对他们思想自由的武器。既然战争是普遍宣传的核心点，民主的弥天大谎就变得显而易见了。自由即奴役。民主即独裁。左即右。一切既是真理又是其反面。
Anyway, I have bought a house, an old one in a medieval village in the mountains, at five kilometers from the city. Many things to repair. So I am a dirty owner, one to be hung. I enjoy very much to make up the arrangements of a house without referring to anyone. My new address [MUMBLING]. I do not know if I shall go to the US soon, maybe so, maybe not. Did you receive my postcard from Morocco? The page is over. Ciao, Paul.
总之，我买了一座房子，在离城市五公里远的山区一个中世纪村庄里，是一座老房子。有很多东西要修理。所以我是一个脏兮兮的业主，该被吊死的那种。我非常享受不参考任何人来布置房子。我的新地址[嘟囔声]。我不知道我是否很快会去美国，也许会，也许不会。你收到我从摩洛哥寄的明信片了吗？信纸写完了。再见，保罗。
Before I choose another one, I'll read you one sentence of another letter. This is a letter that a friend of mine was given. Basically, she started to see this guy. They went out on a date or two, and nothing much was happening. And then he showed her this letter. It's one of those Christmas letters of what's going on in your life. And she only had to read a sentence or two, and decided she would never see him again.
在选择下一封之前，我先读一封信里的一句话。这是一个朋友收到的信。基本上，她开始和这个家伙约会。他们出去约会了一两次，没什么进展。然后他给她看了这封信。那是那种讲述你生活中发生什么的圣诞信件。她只读了一两句，就决定再也不见他了。
The letter begins, ho, ho, ho, these are the words I now use to describe my ex-wife. Next reader, Jenny Magnus.
信的开头是：嚯、嚯、嚯，这就是我现在用来形容我前妻的词。下一位读者，珍妮·马格努斯。
All right, this is a letter that I received. It's addressed to me, so my name is Jenny Magnus. And on the envelope it says, lessons for advanced beginners. And then in the back, it says, burn after reading.
好的，这是一封我收到的信。收信人是我，所以我的名字是珍妮·马格努斯。信封上写着“进阶初学者课程”。背面写着“读后即焚”。
Dear Ms. Magnus, I can imagine how easy it must be to discover what art is all about, and then use your facile capacity to steal symbols, ideas, quotes, et cetera and combine them in an enigmatic collage-type structure, making your work seem abstruse when, in fact, it is very conventional indeed.
亲爱的马格努斯女士，我可以想象发现艺术是什么感觉是多么容易，然后用你肤浅的能力去窃取符号、想法、语录等等，将它们组合成一种令人费解的拼贴结构，让你的作品看起来深奥，而事实上，它们确实非常传统。
Holstein Park. I almost fell off my chair when, during one of your pieces, you imply that you are, quote "a really good artist." After sitting there, listening to you chant, mama, mama, mama, mama, mama, which you got from Janov's book, Primal Scream -- I shop through paperbacks at thrift stores too-- then hearing you chant, give it to me, give it to me, give it to me, give it to me, give it to me, I sat there wondering just how conventional some pretentious chick dressed in black can be.
霍尔斯坦公园。当你在你的作品中暗示你是“一个真正的好艺术家”时，我差点从椅子上掉下来。坐在那里听你唱“妈妈，妈妈，妈妈，妈妈，妈妈”——那你是从简诺夫的《原始呐喊》书里抄来的——我也在旧货店买平装书看——然后听你唱“给我，给我，给我，给我，给我”，我坐在那里想，一个穿着黑衣、装腔作势的妞到底能有多传统。
I, by the way, use chick lightly, since you are not very feminine. In fact, you are nothing but a contrived, self deceiving, selfish, not overly bright, mediocre joke. You might be able to fool the poseurs who hang around Urbis Orbis flattering your brother, pretending to know, but not me, babe. Not me, babe.
顺便说一下，我用“妞”这个词是很轻的，因为你一点也不女性化。事实上，你只是一个虚伪、自欺欺人、自私、不太聪明、平庸的笑话。你也许能骗过那些在乌尔比斯奥比斯周围晃荡、讨好你哥哥、假装懂行的装模作样者，但骗不了我，宝贝。骗不了我，宝贝。
I use babe, lightly. You are not a babe. You have no sensuality, no charm, no looks, et cetera. Without affectation, without deliberately taking steps to appear avant, where would you be? Nothing comes naturally to you, does it? You really have to steal, and grub, and labor. In fact, you are perusing this letter for material right now, I bet.
我用“宝贝”这个词是很轻的。你不是宝贝。你没有性感，没有魅力，没有颜值等等。如果去掉伪装，不去刻意显得前卫，你会在哪里？你什么东西都不是自然而然出来的，对吧？你真的必须去偷，去搜刮，去劳作。事实上，我敢打赌你现在正在读这封信找素材。
I realized how repressed and affected you are during Losers Alias. And thank God for the fire which started, or you'd probably still be on the floor reciting your brother tripe. You are just too, too uptight, baby. You think you can act uninhibited. But why do you want to? Is it that important to you that you seem to yourself and others as if you are special? You are quite interesting. The only person with absolutely no substance I've ever met. How did you get so [BLEEP]? Give up art-- you're no good at it anyway-- and save your [BLEEP] ass. Sincerely, Mason 32 degrees. PS. Well, I've done my good deed for tonight.
我在《失败者别名》中意识到你是多么压抑和做作。感谢上帝发生了火灾，不然你可能还在地板上背诵你哥哥的垃圾。你太紧绷了，宝贝。你以为你可以表现得无拘无束。但你为什么要那样做呢？显得你自己和别人以为你很特别对你那么重要吗？你很有趣。是我见过唯一一个完全没有内涵的人。你怎么变得这么[消音]？放弃艺术吧——你本来就不擅长——省省你那[消音]屁股吧。诚挚地，梅森32度。附言：好吧，我今晚做了一件好事。
Jenny, clearly that person has profound hots for you. And it's somebody who was really turned on, no question about it.
珍妮，很明显那个人对你有强烈的兴趣。毫无疑问，这是一个被你深深吸引的人。
Coming up, more letters from everyday people in a minute, when our program continues.
稍后，节目继续，会有更多来自普通人的信件。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks on our program, we bring you stories by writers and documentary producers. But this week we're trying a little radio experiment. Playwright David Hauptschein and I have advertised, inviting people to a very intimate theater in Chicago called the Lunar Cabaret, maybe 85 or 90 people in here. And we've invited them to bring letters-- ones they have gotten, ones they have sent, ones they have found-- to read on stage. And our next reader.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在大多数周，我们为您带来作家和纪录片制作人的故事。但这周我们正在尝试一个小小的广播实验。剧作家大卫·霍普沙因和我发布了征集启事，邀请人们来到芝加哥一家非常亲密的剧院——月球歌舞厅，现场大概有85或90人。我们邀请他们带着信件——收到的、寄出的、发现的——上台朗读。下一位读者。
Joe Fosco, coming up here to read email.
乔·福斯科，上来读电子邮件。
This is email. This guy, this is kind of a stream of consciousness thing. He's writing it from school. He's in the computer lab. And the only thing I want to mention, he keeps referring to the cluster. And that's what he's referring to, the computer lab with all the things around. You'll find out what he's upset about at the end. I'm going to start in the middle.
这是电子邮件。这个家伙写的东西有点意识流。他在学校写的。他在计算机实验室。我只想提一点，他一直提到“集群”。他指的就是计算机实验室，周围都是电脑。最后你会知道他在为什么而烦恼。我从中间开始读。
There is this guy sitting across the row of computers from me that has his left ear pierced many, many times. I'm trying to count. There are at least five metal rings going through his ear. I'm trying not to be too obvious looking at him. Yeah, it looks like five or six, at least, all up and down his ear.
有一个坐在电脑桌对面那一排的家伙，左耳打了好多洞。我正试着数数。他的耳朵上至少有五个金属环。我尽量不那么明显地盯着他看。是的，看起来至少有五六个，沿着耳朵上下排列。
You do see some interesting ones in these clusters, that's for sure. Then there is this one guy, Sparky. I don't think I have ever been in this cluster, and  he wasn't here or didn't stop in for a minute. Same thing for this other girl, KGB Slut, as we call her. She's always here too. Shooter is here most of the times I am too. OK, some girl just came in who was wearing what, essentially, looks to me like a rug or a piece of carpet with some holes cut in it. She's gone now.
在这些集群里确实能看到一些有趣的家伙。还有一个叫斯帕基的家伙。我想我从没进过这个集群，而他不在或者没停留片刻。那个女孩也一样，我们叫她“KGB荡妇”。她也总是在这儿。我大部分时间在的时候，射手也在这儿。好吧，刚进来一个女孩，穿着基本上看起来像是一块地毯或是一片剪了洞的地毯。她现在走了。
Who else is always in this cluster? Hm, I just realized, I probably shouldn't talk about KGB Slut girl, since she'll probably see this sooner or later, or something. Ah, who cares. What's she going to do, get the geek patrol after me or something? Oh yeah, the other day I was in here, and she had the audacity to talk about my Ronald Reagan screensaver.
还有谁总是出现在这个集群？嗯，我刚刚意识到，我大概不应该谈论KGB荡妇女孩，因为她迟早会看到这个的。啊，谁在乎呢。她能怎么样，让极客巡逻队来找我吗？哦，对了，那天我在的时候，她竟然敢谈论我的罗纳德·里根屏保。
Yeah, it definitely looks like a rug, a Mexican or southwestern type, by its colors, I guess. And it's got little rug-string things at its edges. It does kind of have a collar. Just a few short minutes ago, I walked over to the faculty dining room in Skibo. There was a physics department barbecue that was supposed to be going on. I wasn't sure if I should go. I mean, it's free food, and that can be hard to pass up. Plus, if it's a real barbecue, it'll be free beef, real food, for real people, what's for dinner, my favorite food.
是的，它看起来确实像块地毯，墨西哥或西南风格的，我想是因为颜色。边缘还有点地毯流苏。它确实有点领子。就在几分钟前，我走到斯基博的教职员工餐厅。那里原定有个物理系的烧烤聚会。我不确定我是否该去。我的意思是，有免费食物，很难错过。再说，如果是真正的烧烤，那会有免费牛肉，真正的食物，为真正的人，晚餐吃什么，我最喜欢的食物。
I was extremely disheartened by what I saw, by what these people call a barbecue. Here is my image of what a barbecue is. A bunch of people outside, standing or sitting around, beers in hand, talking informally with one another. The sizzle of meat on the grill, and the sweet smell of cooking beef fill the air, and everyone is happy and jolly, and life seems so much easier.
我对我所见到的感到极其沮丧，这些家伙把那称为烧烤。我对烧烤的形象是这样的：一群人在外面，站着或坐着，手里拿着啤酒，随意交谈。烤架上肉的咝咝声和烹饪牛肉的甜美气味弥漫在空气中，每个人都快乐而欢乐，生活看起来容易得多。
The barbecue is sort of a tonic for the [? dour ?] of everyday life, a reminder of a sort of greater purpose than 40 hours of work a week. And yet, barbecue is not just a reminder of that purpose, but, in many ways, is that purpose. For barbecue is one of the great binding elements of the universe. That sort of metaphysical playdough that maybe can be shaped and molded but not defined.
烧烤对于日常生活的[？乏味？]来说是一种补药，提醒人们有一种比每周工作40小时更伟大的目的。然而，烧烤不仅仅是这种提醒，在许多方面，它本身就是那个目的。因为烧烤是宇宙中伟大的结合元素之一。那种元物理学的橡皮泥，也许可以被塑造和成型，但无法被定义。
And seeing where I come from, you can understand my shock and horror at what I saw being called a barbecue this evening in the faculty dining room. Oh, I did not stay for long, no. In the scant few seconds that I did venture into this room, what I did see scared me mightily. And I did not care to see more. So this information I bring you now is likely not even complete, not a full accounting of the barbecue perversions that occurred within.
看看我的背景，你可以理解我今晚在教职员工餐厅看到被称为烧烤时感到的震惊和恐惧。哦，我没待太久，不。在我冒险进入那个房间的那短短几秒钟里，我所看到的把我吓坏了。我不想看更多。所以我现在带给你们的信息可能甚至不完整，不是对其中发生的烧烤亵渎行为的完整说明。
I saw people seated at tables, many tables, which were organized in a regular, orderly fashion. These people were not conversing amongst themselves, not mingling, not understanding the sweet bliss that is true barbecue.
我看到人们坐在桌子旁，很多桌子，以一种规则、有序的方式组织着。这些人没有在交谈，没有在交流，不理解那种真正的烧烤所带来的甜蜜快乐。
There was a speaker-- yes, a speaker-- at a podium, and the assembled masses applauded him, not understanding that it is not barbecue's purpose to enlighten participants upon matters of fact or scientific knowledge. But that barbecue is inherently enlightening into matters of a more ontological nature. And there were waiters and waitresses roaming the room, serving food, for the gathered horde did not understand proper methodology of a barbecue. At these sights I fled, for I had seen enough evils, and their mere presence was nearly overpowering.
有一个演讲者——是的，演讲者——在讲台上，聚集的大众为他鼓掌，不理解烧烤的目的不是启发参与者关于事实或科学知识的问题。而是烧烤本身就是一种对更本体论性质事物的启迪。还有服务员在房间里走动，供应食物，因为聚集的群体不理解烧烤的正确方法。看到这些场景我逃跑了，因为我见过了足够的邪恶，他们的存在几乎是压倒性的。
My message is not one of vilification or condemnation, but rather one of information, one seeking to create awareness of what true barbecue is in its virtually boundless possibilities to create things. Albeit mostly immaterial of a whole and good nature.
我的信息不是为了诋毁或谴责，而是一种信息，一种寻求让人们意识到什么是真正的烧烤，以及它在创造事物方面几乎无穷无尽的可能性。尽管大部分是非物质的，且本质是完整和美好的。
It is my heartfelt hope that future barbecuers will at least recognize these possibilities, and consider the ways of true barbecue through which they are achieved. For barbecue provides a light, a beacon of good for mankind. And without proper respect for and methods of true barbecue, this knowledge will be lost, and the future of mankind will be muddled and uncertain. God bless you, and God bless barbecue.
我衷心地希望未来的烧烤者至少能认识到这些可能性，并考虑通过它们来实现真正烧烤的方式。因为烧烤提供了一种光，一种人类美好的灯塔。如果没有对真正烧烤的尊重和方法，这种知识将丢失，人类的未来将变得混乱和不确定。上帝保佑你，上帝保佑烧烤。
David, you've done these letter shows around Chicago for a couple years. Why did you decide to do them?
大卫，你在芝加哥做这些信件秀已经几年了。为什么你决定做这些？
Well, that letter was a good example, actually. I used to host a lot of spoken word events, fiction, poetry readings. And I found the events were getting predictable. I was getting bored by a lot of the writing.
嗯，那封信就是一个很好的例子。我过去主持过很多口语艺术活动、小说、诗歌朗诵。我发现这些活动变得可以预测了。我对很多写作感到厌烦。
I think when people write just for themselves or to one other person, they are not looking over their shoulder at literary conventions. They are not worried about what the editor is going to say. They're not worried about, a lot of times, sounding dumb. And consequently, they're much freer with their expression, both stylistically and in terms of what they're willing to talk about.
我认为当人们只为自己或为某一个人写信时，他们不会背负着文学传统。他们不担心编辑会怎么说。他们通常也不担心听起来很蠢。因此，他们的表达更自由，无论是在文体上还是在他们愿意谈论的内容上。
For example, barbecue. A man's obsessed with barbecue, he'll write about barbecue if it's an email. But if he's going to a poetry reading, most likely he won't read about barbecue. He'll probably read a poem about apartheid or something like that, something politically important. And they are very unpredictable. And it's just--
例如，烧烤。一个对烧烤痴迷的人，如果是写电子邮件，他会写烧烤。但如果他是去参加诗歌朗诵会，他很可能不会读关于烧烤的东西。他可能会读一首关于种族隔离的诗之类的，一些政治上重要的事情。他们是非常不可预测的。而且这只是——
You get material that was more raw?
你得到的内容更原始？
Yeah, it's more raw. Really, what I'm interested in, is getting inside people's heads. And I really like the letters-- this is my personal interest-- when I feel like I'm looking at someone's subconscious and seeing how they really are, whether it's a found letter, or whatever.
是的，更原始。实际上，我感兴趣的是进入人们的头脑。我真的很喜欢这些信件——这是我的个人兴趣——当我感觉像是在审视某人的潜意识，看到他们真实的样子时，无论是发现的信件，还是别的什么。
Well, our next reader, Susan.
嗯，我们的下一位读者，苏珊。
Susan.
苏珊。
These are correspondence from a marriage between Sparky and Nadine. There's a poem in it, which I won't take up the whole time to read.
这些是斯帕基和娜丁婚姻中的通信。里面有一首诗，但我不会花整个时间去读它。
Sparky, all the words, all the thank yous could never convey the depth and scope of my love and gratitude for you. May we forever uncover, unfold, our love, our passion, our joy, and laugh our way through this great adventure. I love you, Nadine. And that was written September 12, 1992.
斯帕基，所有的言语，所有的感谢都无法表达我对你的爱和感激的深度和广度。愿我们永远去探索、去展开我们的爱、我们的激情、我们的快乐，并笑着度过这场伟大的冒险。我爱你，娜丁。那是1992年9月12日写的。
And this next letter is written from Sparky on December 24, 1993. Dear Nadine, I love you. I love you very, very much. This Christmas has brought me many gifts that I never knew existed before. I am learning about humility, patience, and trust. And most of all, I am learning about unconditional love. Excuse me. This year, I can't give you the material Christmas that I'd like to, that you deserve. I can't even give you the card I bought for you, because I lost it. Instead I can give you some other stuff now and some material stuff later.
下一封信是斯帕基在1993年12月24日写的。亲爱的娜丁，我爱你。我非常非常爱你。这个圣诞节带给了我许多我以前从未知道存在的礼物。我正在学习关于谦卑、耐心和信任。最重要的是，我正在学习关于无条件的爱。请原谅。今年，我不能给你我想要的、你应得的物质圣诞礼物。我甚至不能给你我买给你的贺卡，因为我把它弄丢了。取而代之的是，我现在可以给你一些别的东西，稍后再给你一些物质的东西。
First one, good for one really good body massage. Second one, good for one really good foot massage. The above two items may be redeemed any time and aren't really gifts, because you can have those anytime you want. Number three, good for one day of non-sarcasm. Redeem by 8:00 AM, day of use. And the fourth is good for one day of total slavery, any kind. Redeem with 24 hours advance notice to ensure proper scheduling. Merry Christmas, your love.
第一件，可以兑换一次非常好的全身按摩。第二件，可以兑换一次非常好的足部按摩。以上两项可以随时兑换，其实算不上什么礼物，因为你随时都可以要求这些。第三件，可以兑换一整天不说讽刺的话。请在当天使用前早上8点前兑换。第四件，可以兑换一整天完全的奴役，任何种类。请提前24小时通知以确保适当的时间安排。圣诞快乐，爱你的人。
And the last part of the correspondence. Dated January 12, 1996. To Nadine, in regard to the marriage of Sparky and Nadine. Dear Nadine, enclosed please find our proposed judgment of dissolution of marriage, for your review. Please advise me regarding changes and corrections. Sincerely, someone, an attorney.
通信的最后部分。日期是1996年1月12日。致娜丁，关于斯帕基和娜丁的婚姻。亲爱的娜丁，随信附上我们拟定的解除婚姻关系的判决书，请查阅。如有更改和更正，请告知我。诚挚地，某人，律师。
Our next reader, pulled from our bowl of readers, John S.
我们的下一位读者，从我们的读者碗里抽出来的，约翰·S。
You look like a guy who wants to hold on to the rhinoceros. Am I right about that?
你看上去是个想抓着犀牛的家伙。我猜对了吗？
Cool. I found this in the undergraduate library at the University of Illinois, in the computer lab. April 7, 1994. Dear Mr. V., hello, my name is Lois. I caught all three of your appearances on Jeopardy! and was greatly impressed. You are a brilliant, serious, dignified, modest, and beautiful young man. I was sorry to see your winning streak come to an end. Those categories on the last show were silly anyway. Roots, nursery rhyme, deli? Please.
酷。我在伊利诺伊大学的本科图书馆，在计算机实验室里发现了这个。1994年4月7日。亲爱的V先生，你好，我的名字是洛伊丝。我看了你所有三次在《危险边缘》的表现，印象非常深刻。你是一个聪明、严肃、端庄、谦虚而美丽的年轻人。很遗憾看到你的连胜结束了。最后一场比赛的类别太愚蠢了。根，童谣，熟食店？拜托。
And when Alex teased you about Paris, romance, and cousins, my heart nearly melted. In case you're interested, I am an attractive 21 year old brunette studying economics and political science at the University of Illinois. And I love parrots and cats, too. If you'd like, I could send you my picture. If not, have a wonderful life, and I hope to be a patient of yours some day. Au revoir. Sincerely-- and it leaves an address.
当你提到巴黎、浪漫和表亲时，我的心都快融化了。如果你感兴趣，我是一个21岁的有吸引力的黑发女孩，在伊利诺伊大学学习经济学和政治学。我也爱鹦鹉和猫。如果你愿意，我可以寄我的照片给你。如果不愿意，祝你生活愉快，希望有一天能成为你的病人。再见。诚挚地——并留下了地址。
The second one I found, it was posted on a bulletin board in the English building at the University of Illinois. Hello. My name is K. I am a 20 year old, single white male. I'm about five foot six, brown hair, and have a mustache and beard. My grandmother's house is up for sale, and I really want it. I realize this is superficial, but I'm seeking, preferably, a single white female, non-smoker, 18 to 35, wealthy slash gorgeous slash beautiful model-type woman for marriage. Or I want a quote unquote "sugar mommy." A sugar daddy spoils young women, so I figure a sugar mommy spoils young men.
我发现的第二封信，张贴在伊利诺伊大学英语大楼的布告栏上。你好。我的名字是K。我是一个20岁的单身白人男性。我大约五英尺六英寸高，棕色头发，留着小胡子和胡须。我祖母的房子要出售，我真的想要它。我意识到这很肤浅，但我正在寻找，最好是一位单身白人女性，不吸烟，18到35岁，富有、华丽、漂亮的模特型女性结婚。或者我想要一个“糖妈”。糖爹宠爱年轻女性，所以我想糖妈宠爱年轻男性。
Please send a photo. I am a junior and a history major. This realty company is selling my grandmother's house for $49,900. I lived in the house for 15 years with my grandmother. Below is a photo of the house and one of me. And he gives the realty's phone number. If you are not interested, then please pass this flyer to your female friends. I'm very shy, so I haven't enclosed my phone number. And at the bottom it says, please hurry, time is running out.
请寄一张照片。我是大三学生，历史专业。这家房地产公司以49,900美元的价格出售我祖母的房子。我和我祖母在那房子里住了15年。下面是房子的照片和我的照片。他留下了房地产公司的电话号码。如果你不感兴趣，请把这张传单传给你的女性朋友。我很害羞，所以没附上我的电话号码。底部写着，请快点，时间不多了。
Wait, wait, before you go. Let's see the picture. You guys can't see this. He's a very serious looking guy in a tie.
等等，等等，在你走之前。让我们看看照片。你们看不见这个。他是一个戴着领带，看起来非常严肃的家伙。
Next person.
下一位。
Our next reader, Kara [? Schenk ?].
我们的下一位读者，卡拉[？申克？]。
My letter is written on the back of a CBGB's flyer from New York, from a guy that I met while I was in Paris. He was cycling through Europe. Dear Kara, Hey, I haven't written to you in a long time. I had been in the midst of a personal and emotional whirlwind. Whoosh, and the wind went rushing through my brain and into my body chemistry. And God spoke to me and said, get a grip, dude. Whereas you've been sitting at work wishing you were on vacation, I've been sitting in my parents' house and on the couches of several friends wishing that I had work to do. Without the stable base of my own place, it was indeed difficult to focus on anything. Socializing? Yes. Continued cycling around? Yes. Work? Absolutely no.
我的信写在纽约CBGB音乐节传单的背面，是一个我在巴黎认识的家伙写的。他当时正在欧洲骑行。亲爱的卡拉，嘿，我好久没写信给你了。我一直处于个人和情感的漩涡中。呼，风吹过我的大脑进入我的身体化学反应。上帝对我说话，说，振作起来，老兄。而你一直在工作中坐着希望自己在度假，我一直坐在父母家里和几个朋友的沙发上，希望有工作可做。没有自己住所的稳定基础，确实很难专注于任何事情。社交？是的。继续骑行？是的。工作？绝对没有。
Right now, as I write to you, I am glowing like a pregnant woman. After several weeks of trying to get in this film production company, playing my cards and doing spot jobs for the dude who runs it-- who is our age, is the son of a Time-Warner Company huge corporate executive, has access to the mass media, as well as access to, no kidding, millions of dollars-- I've emerged with, yes, a job. How fortunate for me and my wonderful temperament and abilities. He needs me to save his project, to co-rewrite the story, as well as edit the thing, a short 30 minute film-poem on the Hudson Valley of Upstate New York.
现在，当我写信给你的时候，我像个孕妇一样容光焕发。经过几周努力进入这家电影制作公司，打出我的牌，为经营它的家伙做点琐事——他跟我们同龄，是时代华纳公司一位巨大企业高管的儿子，能接触大众媒体，而且还能接触到——不骗你——数百万美元——我终于得到了一份工作。我的性情和能力真是太幸运了。他需要我来拯救他的项目，重新改写故事，以及剪辑那东西，一部关于纽约州北部哈德逊河谷的30分钟短片诗。
He is letting me put my whole lower leg in the door, never mind my foot. I am excited and ready to begin work. I am going to do a great job for him. So now, I am slightly more sane, more filled with better cheer, and open to a little sharing and communication with several individuals. It is a pleasure to correspond with you. It was certainly a pleasure to hang out in Paris. Hoping to hear from you soon. Why not send along some writing samples, so that we may begin to fully share our literary interests and creations? Love and kisses, Sparky. PS, thank you so much for the photos. I look pretty good. I'm shocked.
他让我把整个小腿都伸进了门里，别提脚了。我很兴奋，准备开始工作。我会为他做好工作的。所以现在，我稍微理智了一点，充满了更好的心情，并对与几个人分享和交流持开放态度。能和你通信是我的荣幸。在巴黎一起玩确实很愉快。希望能很快收到你的来信。为什么不寄一些写作样本过来，让我们开始充分分享我们的文学兴趣和创作呢？吻，斯帕基。附言：非常感谢照片。我看起来还不错。我很震惊。
Next reader. Is this Miki Greenberg? Did you fill one of these out?
下一位读者。这是米基·格林伯格吗？你填过这个表吗？
Yes I did.
是的，我填过。
OK.
好的。
Miki?
米基？
Miki is running sound for us.
米基正在为我们运行音响。
Who's going to run sound while you are coming up here, Miki? You're invaluable. You can't be taken away from this. It's like the pilot coming back to chitchat with the passengers. OK, here we go. Let's hope the plane doesn't crash.
当你上来的时候，谁来运行音响，米基？你是无价之宝。你不能被带离岗位。这就像飞行员回到后面和乘客闲聊。好了，我们开始吧。希望飞机别坠毁。
I heard about a pilot who used to do that as a joke. Sit in the back in the regular, on those little Caribbean flights. The pilot would sit in the back in regular clothes, and then he'd wait till everyone got on, and wait about 15 minutes and say, damn it, where is that pilot? I'm going to fly this thing myself. Go up in front, and all the passengers would be like freaking out.
我听说过一个飞行员，他曾经拿这个开玩笑。坐在加勒比海的小飞机后排。飞行员穿上便装坐在后面，等所有人都上去了，等了大约15分钟然后说，该死，那个飞行员在哪？我要自己开这架飞机。走到前面，所有的乘客都会被吓坏。
This is a letter that comes from someone I do not know. It's from an insurance agency. It comes here to the club. I'm one of the people who runs Lunar Cabaret. And we have a band called the Dysfunctionells that play here every two or three months. The cover of the letter is a psychedelic graphic that says the words, featuring dot, dot, dot, Dysfunctionells psychedelic? Just for the record, the Dysfunctionells are a very folk-based, Bluegrass, rocking band that I love. They're not psychedelic at all. But here's what it says.
这是一封来自我不认识的人的信。来自一家保险代理公司。它寄到了俱乐部。我是运营月球歌舞厅的人之一。我们有一个叫“功能障碍者”的乐队，每两三个月在这里演出一次。信的封面是一张迷幻图案，上面写着：“特色，点，点，点，功能障碍者迷幻？”郑重声明，功能障碍者是一个非常民谣风格的蓝草摇滚乐队，我很爱他们。他们根本不迷幻。但这就是上面写的。
Regarding survival of the fittest. Dear fine club owner, psychedelic light shows. Remember Janice, Jimmy, Jerry, Timothy? What a long, strange trip it has been. Things change. Music certainly changes. Your club featured Dysfunctionells. You have to change to survive. The current issue of Illinois Entertainer features an article titled, "The End of an Era," which describes the closing of what the magazine calls the Midwest's premiere hard rock, heavy metal club. The owner cites, quote unquote "the sky high insurance premiums," as one of the contributing factors in his decision to close the doors permanently on the club. It goes on to talk about why he's underwriting this, financially strong, blah, blah, blah. And then he says, your phone number is 312-327-6666. Ours is 708, blank, blank, blank, 3790. One way or another, let's talk.
关于适者生存。亲爱的俱乐部老板，迷幻灯光秀。记得贾尼斯、吉米、杰瑞、蒂莫西吗？这是一段漫长而奇异的旅程。事情在变。音乐肯定在变。你们俱乐部邀请了功能障碍者。你必须改变才能生存。《伊利诺伊艺人》当前一期有一篇标题为“一个时代的终结”的文章，描述了杂志所称的“中西部首屈一指的硬摇滚、重金属俱乐部”的关闭。老板引用了“高昂的保险费”作为他决定永久关闭俱乐部的原因之一。它继续谈论为什么他要承保这个，财务实力雄厚，等等等等。然后他说，你的电话号码是312-327-6666。我们的是708，空白，空白，空白，3790。无论如何，让我们谈谈吧。
And that's to sell insurance?
那是为了卖保险？
I think he wanted to sell us some insurance. I think he wanted to. This is the weirdest insurance letter I've ever gotten in my life.
我想他是想卖给我们一些保险。我想他是想。这是我这辈子收到过最奇怪的保险信。
Next, David Sadowski.
下一位，大卫·萨多斯基。
Letters from Bullwinkle. In 1983, at the Chicago International Film Festival, they had a tribute to Rocky and Bullwinkle. And I talked to Bill Scott and June Foray, who did the voices of Bullwinkle and Rocky, afterward. First, here's part of what they said at that event.
来自布尔温克尔的信。1983年，在芝加哥国际电影节上，他们举办了一场向《洛奇和布尔温克尔》致敬的活动。之后我采访了为洛奇和布尔温克尔配音的比尔·斯科特和琼·福雷。首先，这是他们在那个活动上说的一部分。
How long did it take for you to develop the characterizations? Bill Scott-- About a minute and a half. No, as a matter of fact, the strange thing was, June got slickered into doing Rocky over a drunken martini lunch with Jay Ward. She would have agreed to anything. Can you do a flying squirrel? Oh sure, I can do a flying squirrel. I was a writer, and Jay Ward does not read. And the only way he knew what was in the script, was if I would read them to him.
你们花了多久开发这些角色性格？比尔·斯科特——大约一分半钟。不，事实上，奇怪的事情是，琼是在一次醉酒的马提尼午餐中被杰·沃德哄骗去做洛奇的。她本会同意任何事。你能模仿一只飞鼠吗？哦，当然，我能模仿飞鼠。我是个编剧，杰·沃德根本不读书。他知道剧本里有什么的唯一方法就是我读给他听。
And I read him the voices on the way to the recording session, first one, right. And there's June, there's Paul Frees, Bill Conrad, all those wonderful people. And I said to him, who's going to read Bullwinkle? And he said, oh, I thought you were. And that's how much preparation I had for the part of Bullwinkle Moose.
我在去录音棚的路上读给他听，第一个，对吧。然后琼在那里，保罗·弗里斯，比尔·康拉德，所有那些很棒的人。我对他说，谁来读布尔温克尔？他说，哦，我以为你会。这就是我为布尔温克尔麋鹿这个角色所做的准备。
So afterward, I talked to them, asked them some more questions. And I got their autographs here on this ticket. It says, Hi-dee to old Dave from old Bullwinkle and Bill Scott, plus Rocky, Natasha, Nell, and June Foray. But anyway, afterward, I told Bill Scott I wanted to write a book about The Rocky and Bullwinkle Show . And he said, get in line. I still have yet to see one, though.
所以之后，我采访了他们，问了他们更多问题。我在这张票上得到了他们的签名。上面写着：“给老戴夫的问候，来自老布尔温克尔和比尔·斯科特，还有洛奇、娜塔莎、内尔和琼·福雷。”但无论如何，之后，我告诉比尔·斯科特我想写一本关于《洛奇和布尔温克尔秀》的书。他说，去排队吧。虽然我至今还没看到一本。
And then I told him I had a 78 RPM record of Rocky and Bullwinkle. It was a song called, "I Was Born to be Airborne." He said, there is no such thing. This record, he said, didn't exist. But then I told him that I had taped all the shows off the air, off WGN. And I had them all on videotape. And he got excited, because he had never seen most of the shows in their original form. And he had me make copies for them. So Bullwinkle, Bill Scott, paid me to make videotapes, copies of The Rocky and Bullwinkle Shows for him.
然后我告诉他我有一张《洛奇和布尔温克尔》的78转唱片。那是首歌叫《我注定要空降》。他说，根本没那东西。他说，这张唱片不存在。但我告诉他我从WGN电台录制了所有节目。我把它们都录在录像带上了。他很兴奋，因为他从未以原始形式看过大多数节目。他让我为他们制作拷贝。所以布尔温克尔，比尔·斯科特，付钱让我制作录像带，复制《洛奇和布尔温克尔秀》给他。
So we kept up a little bit of a correspondence. And I'll just read from some of these letters. Good luck with the taping. I look forward to seeing some of the shows that I've never seen before. Here with another payment for your taping [? chores. ?] This stuff looks very good, although I am weary of the pull a rabbit out of my hat stuff. And I'm depressed at how fast and skimpy the Mr. Know-It-Alls had to be done. But the other material is very fresh and funny to me.
所以我们保持了一点通信。我只读其中几封信。祝录制顺利。我期待看到一些我从未看过的节目。这是你录制费用的另一笔款项。这些东西看起来很棒，尽管我对从帽子里拿出兔子的东西感到厌倦。我对“万事通先生”必须要做得那么快和吝啬感到沮丧。但其他素材对我来说非常新鲜和有趣。
Some of it I even remember. Though I must say that the episode of Bumbling Brothers, when Conrad breaks up at the end, was a complete surprise. I thought it was hysterical. For god's sake, please record the Hoppitys. I've never seen one of them. I wrote the Hoppity episodes, I think. Though I may have rewritten somebody else's stuff. Tell you better after I see them. I can usually recognize my own stuff. I also did the voice of Fillmore Bear, but I was in a period of relative modesty at the time, and was in favor of just taking one credit on a show, preferably the highest in the production hierarchy. I don't know that I'd do it again.
有些我甚至还记得。尽管我必须说，“笨拙兄弟”的那集，当康拉德在最后崩溃时，是一个完全的惊喜。我觉得那简直歇斯底里。看在上帝份上，请录下霍皮蒂系列。我从未见过其中任何一集。我想是我写了霍皮蒂的剧集。尽管我可能重写了别人的东西。看完之后告诉你。我通常能认出我自己的东西。我也为菲尔莫尔熊配音，但我当时处于一个相对谦虚的时期，倾向于只在节目中署名一次，最好是制作层级中最高的那个。我不知道我会不会再做一次。
And anyway, the upshot of it was, the taping project was never completed. Because shortly after receiving the fourth letter from him, Bill Scott had a heart attack and died at the age of 65. And so, while that may have been a sad thing, one thing that they did say at the festival was that-- somebody asked, why did they stop doing the show? And they said, well, you know, we had enough for syndication, but we could have gone on forever. And in syndication, they will.
总之，结果是，录制项目从未完成。因为在收到他的第四封信后不久，比尔·斯科特心脏病发作，在65岁时去世了。所以，虽然这可能是一件悲伤的事，但他们在电影节上说的一件事是——有人问，他们为什么停止做这个节目？他们说，嗯，你知道，我们有足够的集数供联合播放了，但我们可以永远做下去。而在联合播放中，他们确实会永远播放。
Who would have thought we'd have a Rocky and Bullwinkle expert here? Thank you.
谁会想到这里会有一位《洛奇和布尔温克尔》专家？谢谢。
Andrew Fenchel. While he's taking the stage, Andrew is wearing an Iron Maiden tee-shirt.
安德鲁·芬切尔。在他上台的时候，安德鲁穿着一件铁娘子T恤。
Kick ass.
太棒了。
I found this letter in the street, in my neighborhood. I think it won't really need any other introduction except that, where the letter writer refers to Vienna, I think it's safe to assume that that's not Austria. OK. Time, 10:00 PM. June 10, '96. Dear Carla, what's up babe? How are you doing? Fine, I hope. Well, I'm in Vienna. But I didn't forget to write. Baby, I miss you. I can't wait to see you. I've been thinking about you all the time, and I can't stop. I got into a fight in here with a king, and for that, I got two weeks in the hole.
我在街上发现了这封信，在我家附近。我想它不需要任何其他介绍，只是当信件作者提到维也纳时，我认为可以安全地假设那不是奥地利。好的。时间，晚上10点。96年6月10日。亲爱的卡拉，怎么了宝贝？你好吗？希望你很好。嗯，我在维也纳。但我没忘记写信。宝贝，我想你。我迫不及待想见你。我一直都在想你，我无法停止。我在这里和一个家伙打了一架，因此，我被关了两周禁闭。
Baby, I hope you're not talking to someone else. I've been waiting for your letters, but I haven't received any yet. What's up with that? Carla, I feel that you don't love me anymore. Baby, I love you more than what you could ever know. I miss making love to you, kissing you. Please, send me some pictures of you. When I get out of here, I'm going to get a job. I'll even quit gang banging if you show me you love me.
宝贝，我希望你没在跟别人说话。我一直等着你的信，但我还没收到任何信。那是怎么回事？卡拉，我觉得你不爱我了。宝贝，我爱你胜过你能知道的一切。我想念和你做爱，亲吻你。请寄一些你的照片给我。当我从这里出去，我会找份工作。如果你让我看到你爱我，我甚至会戒掉帮派活动。
Carla, what do you mean when you say, you went from 100% to 50%? I don't understand. I haven't been cheating on you. And I'll be with you all the time when I get out. Carla, I care about you a lot. You just don't know. Why is your mom going to kick you out? What have you done? Please, don't lie to me. Are you [BLEEP] around with someone else? Staying out late? What is it? I've got the feeling you are seeing someone else, but I guess I can't trip, so long as when I get out, you come back to me.
卡拉，当你对我说，你从100%变成了50%是什么意思？我不明白。我没对你撒谎。当我出去后我会一直和你在一起。卡拉，我很在乎你。你就是不知道。你妈妈为什么要赶你走？你做了什么？请别对我撒谎。你有没有和别人[消音]？在外面待得很晚？那是怎么回事？我有种感觉你在见别人，但我猜我不能计较，只要我出去后，你回到我就行。
What do you mean that you love me, and good luck in life? I get the first part, but not the second. Are you breaking up with me? Are you going away from me? Whatever you do, wherever you go, you'll always be in my heart, Carla. Believe that. I know you think I don't love you anymore, but you're wrong, babe. I said it before, and I'll say it again. I love you, Carla.
你说你爱我，祝我人生好运是什么意思？我理解前半部分，但不理解后半部分。你要和我分手吗？你要离开我吗？无论你做什么，无论你去哪，你永远都会在我心里，卡拉。相信这一点。我知道你认为我不爱你了，但你错了，宝贝。我说过一次，我会再说一遍。我爱你，卡拉。
Our program was produced today by Dolores Wilber and myself, with David Hauptschein, Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margie Rochlin.
我们的节目今天由多洛雷斯·威尔伯和我制作，大卫·霍普沙因、彼得·克洛尼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克共同完成。特约编辑保罗·托夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗奇林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you would like a tape of this program, it's only $10. Call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Again, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
如果您想要本节目的录音，只要10美元。请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，312-832-3380。再重复一遍，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱地址是[email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
WBEZ管理层监督人托里·马拉蒂亚。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI Public Radio International.
PRI公共广播国际。